if I talk about it this one time will
you all stop asking
[Applause]
[Music]
so I'm gonna do something that I have be
mentally resisted doing up to this point
that is I'm gonna talk about Doctor Who
viewing numbers the ratings as a rule of
thumb I don't talk about TV show ratings
the simplest reason is that I don't care
and it's not that I don't care about
whether or not a show I like does well I
care about it insofar as are the ratings
enough to keep it you know on the air
but you can't judge that looking at
episode by episode ratings honestly you
know there were times when a well rated
show will get cancelled there are times
we're gonna show with ratings that don't
seem to justify anything at all we'll
stay on the air forever so like looking
at the ratings rarely gives you a solid
sense of whether something's gonna stick
around or not so I watch for the renewal
announcements and stuff like that that's
about the extent that I care about
ratings and if anybody is wondering why
it seems odd that sometimes I talk about
box office numbers the reason for that
is it's a lot easier for me to wrap my
head and and extrapolate a meaning out
of box office numbers because it's a lot
easier for me with resources like Box
Office Mojo to get the budgets for these
films and and I know enough about box
office returns to know the rules of
thumb for what constitutes a movie
breaking even and what constitutes
something being profitable so I can look
at box office returns and I I know
enough about them to be able to get
something out of that I don't know
enough about how TV ratings work and I
don't care enough to find out that is
the primary reason why I don't talk
about TV ratings in general the reason I
haven't talked about TV ratings for
Doctor Who specifically especially this
series is partially because you all kept
asking like I was really getting
resentful the number of times he were
like you're gonna talk about the the
radius you're gonna talk about the rate
he's here to talk about the rings like
there was one guy I I actually responded
I gave him a longer response I said
never which was a little overly harsh
and I'm clearly now perjuring myself on
that declaration but here we go here's
the thing though I wasn't going to talk
about them until I looked at them
because here's the thing it's not just
that people have been asking me to talk
about the ratings they've been asking
with fairly specific wording which is
are you going to talk about how the
Doctor Who ratings are tanking or some
variation of that and enough people have
been saying it's one of those things
that like people just keep saying and it
shows up over and over and over again
and I'm starting to feel like a lot of
people are just believing that because
they're hearing it so much and I didn't
know either way because I didn't care
but i-i've actually not looked at the
numbers and I don't know if these people
are looking at different numbers that
I'm looking at but no so when I say I
don't know if they're pulling numbers
from a resource other than what I used I
used Wikipedia which like I understand
the failings of Wikipedia but I it's for
my purposes I have no reason to doubt it
and so if they're literally just pulling
numbers from somewhere else I don't know
what that is but I'm if they're looking
at the numbers I'm looking at I don't I
don't know how they're drawing that
conclusion so let me go over what those
numbers are so that next time somebody
brings up the ratings I can point them
to this video and then never have to
talk about it again so a couple of
things as I get into this I am NOT going
to discuss at any point in this video
why ratings were higher for some series
lower for some series why they went up
or down on any given episodes I am NOT
talking about any of that I'm only
dealing with the numbers with the
viewing numbers that's it
no extrapolation No
I think it dipped because of this no
none of that second of all when I do
things like discuss averages of us of
any given series I am not counting the
specials so when I ran the numbers to
find out the average of series what
would have been series four I didn't
include the viewing numbers for voyage
of the Damned so you know realize that
those are not part of it because they
skew it severely because the Christmas
specials have always been higher rated
than the series that that Buffett them
on either side so it's cubes things up
in a way that wasn't helpful I think
that oh this is British this is UK
rating numbers that I'm going with
because that's what I could find I tried
to find a reliable source for like the
BBC America ratings and I couldn't find
what at least I couldn't find one that
covered all the series
I found a something that allowed me to
look at series 10 and series 11 and just
sort of looking off those and then
compared with the UK numbers the the
actual raw number way different but the
comparative of like average of series
tend to average so far or series 11 was
about equivalent so that leads me to
believe without having numbers to
confirm it that at the very least US
broadcast ratings have gone up and down
in comparatively similar fashion to the
British ones so again when I talk to
these numbers only talking the British
ratings so all of that said a lot of
preamble let's go I've got notes so at
the time of recording the we've gotten
as far as the episode the witch finders
airing confirmed final viewing numbers
aren't out for that episode so the
numbers I'm gonna give are only up
through ker-blam and before anyone says
well how can you judge one of the
numbers for this series arnout yeah well
you know what all you people who were
asking for me had already come to the
conclusion the show is tanking so if
you're gonna leap to conclusions then
you can't could
sighs me for not waiting so I'm not
bitter at doing this I'm a little bitter
okay so let's get to this series 11 as
of this recording so first seven
episodes and it would be incredibly
unlikely and way out of character for
not only this show but really any show
to suddenly take a massive nosedive of
significant proportions in its last
three episodes of its series but so far
the average for series 11 is eight point
four seven million viewers so that's the
average that is the highest viewing
average of modern era Doctor Who period
prior to this the series of the highest
average was series two with eight point
three six now there are three episodes
left and they are likely to bring that
average down because they're not gonna
be higher than that I would say this has
a very good chance of coming in right
around series two by the time we wrap up
so it's gonna be in the neighborhood
this is this is highest ratings the
show's had since the revival but let's
get more specific let's talk how the
show has been overall so series one
started average was around 8 million
series 2 was the previous peak eight
point three six roughly series three
seven and a half series for about eight
series five seven and three-quarters he
was six seven and a half series seven
and seven and a half series eight seven
and a quarter series nine about six
series ten about five and a half so
here's the other thing you need to
realize the average viewing numbers for
a series of Doctor Who has been trending
downwards since series five so the last
time they went up as opposed to going
down again for the average across the
series that was series 3-2 series four
that was the last time it went up since
then it has been dropping
series / series year-over-year to the
point that series 10 was an all-time low
average wise five point four six million
average and again not going to talk
about any possibilities as to why that
may or may not have been the case that's
just the numbers so not only is this
average high for the series it is an
immediate reversal of of a long-running
trend of gradual declining now if we
look at series 11 in a little bit more
detail a couple of things so it's the
lowest ratings so far this series and
that that's about seven point four six
that's higher than the highest C numbers
highest episode number for series 9 and
series 10 and the even series 8 only had
two episodes that had ratings higher
than the lowest rated episode of series
11 which is KaBlam now since ker-blam so
far is the lowest rated series again as
of time of recording it's worth pointing
out that the ratings have dropped
episode / episode they have been going
down steadily but also it's worth going
out not precipitously it was from seven
point four eight to seven point four six
from the demons of the punjab to KaBlam
it was basically negligible and for all
intents and purposes it was flat so
while technically they have been going
down first of all your premiere episode
and not just on Doctor Who on almost any
show your premiere episode is almost
always your highest rating and it's it
takes a very special kind of show to
have that not be the case something acid
like truly become a water-cooler show
like and and the other thing is even
even if that does happen you're still
gonna have your premiere you're gonna
dip and maybe you'll come back up or
maybe you'll waver back and forth now
Doctor Who series 11 has been dipping
but again not nose-diving and it's
lowest rating even with the decline its
lowest rating this series is still
higher than the highest rating of the
previous two series and is among the top
rated of the previous three series this
is not a nosedive guys if they were
gonna cancel based on viewing numbers
they would have canceled after series 10
that was some weak numbers certainly
compared to will the show have been
capable of before so anyone claiming to
you that series 11 that the numbers of
tanked asked them where they got those
numbers from because again I would like
to know because the numbers that I've
got that is not the picture that's
painted if you want a comparative of a
show that has had its numbers nosedive
in its latest season a show that I don't
talk about but let's just talk about it
as comparative The Walking Dead huh so
The Walking Dead from halfway through
season 3 through the entirety of season
7 didn't have a single episode with
ratings below 10 million viewers then
series 8 they did have actually most of
them below 10 but still close to it
series 9 current season still airing I
think they're their highest-rated
episode for season 9 a little over 6
million it is lower than the lowest
rated episode of the previous season
that's a nosedive when your highest
rating is lower than the lowest rating
you had the previous year that is a
precipitous drop dr. who is literally
the opposite of that because we're
currently in the middle of a series
where the lowest rated episode is the
higher
and anything the previous two series had
aired at all so again people can and
will still have their debates about what
this means because I have no doubt that
there will still be people who will go
what people just tuned in this year for
the novelty you guys wanted to bait what
into what it means you can debate what
it means but what I can tell you is
straight up factually series a lot of a
doctor series 11 of Doctor Who it's not
a ratings disaster it's a hit and it's
brought dr. who up to a much healthier
standing than it's been in a long time
now also use this as an opportunity to
talk about an address in video form
because I've said this elsewhere why I'm
not gonna bring up the rumor that
Chibnall and and/or Jodie Whittaker are
supposedly leaving either midway through
or at the end of the next series if that
ever gets officially announced I will
absolutely talk about it right now it's
a rumor it was a rumor published in one
place with a name source and since then
it was just publishing a bunch of other
places that it got published somewhere
the though again the one thing I will
acknowledge is if people are saying
every episode has lower rated than the
previous one yes that is factual but the
raw numbers are still really high and it
has not been a nosedive drop it has been
what at least when I looked at other
quote-unquote successful TV series
ratings just at a glance for comparisons
for what you usually get for a decline
you know from premiere episode across
the season is not out of line with
standard numbers so that's it this is me
being done talking about Doctor Who
viewing numbers and the other thing is
like even if I cared more I would never
talk about this stuff week over week
because any up or down from one episode
to the next episode doesn't mean
anything like to end like to
not even the not like the people
broadcasting it making it no but that
doesn't that's like that's like tracking
the box office numbers from day to day
and trying to figure out what that means
but know when the seasons done you can
step back and maybe look at a pattern
but again like I said I personally don't
know enough about how TV operation is
done especially in the UK to feel
comfortable extrapolating anything out
of those numbers but that's it I'm done
no more so don't ask me again
not gonna talk about it again there you
go
so that'll wrap up that one Doctor Who
viewing numbers I think it's been a long
time since I've made a video out of
spite I don't like doing that I'll try
not to do that too much so any case
whatever your thoughts are again if
you've got a resource that I don't know
about let me know or whatever else and
keep it respectful please drop something
on the comments let's talk about a whole
bunch of stuff you can do such as like
and subscribe and there's a link down
there for the patreon if you feel like
supporting me that way you don't don't
worry about it other links you can check
out you don't wanna check out those
that's fine too because at the end of
the day folks you are the council I just
run the meetings and until next time
this council is a jerk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]